for me as a kid from the 90s it was
normal for me and for my other comrades
to tattoo a swastika I used to have a
swastik area in the middle of my chest
my name is Philip slapper from Germany
and I'm a former neonati Today I work
with young people to de-radicalize them
and I work as an anti-violence coach in
this box are questions what people are
afraid of asking me to my face
um do you think your fellow neo-nazis
were evil
um well I don't like to talk too much
about my fellow neo-nazis or the group I
was in I think I was evil as a Neo-Nazi
I didn't feel anything for people I had
no empathy within me if if me and my
group would have come to power we would
have destroyed the life of millions of
people in Germany in Europe it would
have come to war with our politics we
wanted so of course we were the
reincarnated evil yeah absolutely what
is the difference between Neo-Nazi and
Nazis
um well that is quite easy
um a Nazi is still a person who lived in
the Third Reich which is still alive
these people are nearly 100 years old
time will take care of the old Nazis now
and neo-nazis are people who uh who
started after 1940 after 1945
so they're the new Nazis and uh yeah
that's the main difference that is the
only difference
would you be friends or date someone
from a different race
um
today in my new life
I would date and befriend with everybody
I sometimes get asked if I find people
today yeah of course I find people
today because but I only find them
because I met them and I don't like
their character or we just don't fit but
in my time as a Neo-Nazi I would have
never been friend with somebody from
different race and would have never been
possible to date somebody I would have
been thrown out of the movement I would
have been a traitor
um it was even so awful that I didn't
even go for foreign food or something so
that'll that would have been an absolute
no-go would you have ever killed someone
for your beliefs
um
yes
um I
especially as a as a young Neo-Nazi I I
was begging for War I thought
um I believed in the world from all
neo-nazis in the 90s I met up with a lot
of neo-nazis who uh Nazis who who were
still in the in the war fighting for
Germany like in the waffner SS or in the
wehrmacht and they had like slogans like
saying
um every generation needs a war to like
to like harden up and uh
and um yeah I would have I would have
killed for my beliefs um in a war and uh
and then
I did not have thoughts on going just
out on the streets and just stabbing
people down or shooting anything
um I I always thought that would just
change nothing did you like Hitler
Hitler is sort of like uh for a National
Socialist there the the light of the
Stars he's like uh he's the he's the
father of national socialism and he was
a he was a big big hero of mine I uh I
tattooed his signature on my on my uh on
my arm and he was for a long for a long
time uh sort of hero two neo-nazis
believe women are second-class citizens
um maybe not second-class citizens there
are looking after an older family
um construct like the man is working the
man makes the decisions the woman looks
after the children gets the children
raises the children and uh but there are
there are new modern Nazis who um they
put women in front of the camera they
work they they walk in front of
demonstrations so the Neo-Nazi movement
shows or we're just not we're not just
uh Neo-Nazi men here look at us we have
women but in the decision in the
politics
um in the parties
um it's always kind of a man thing
um I wouldn't say second-class citizens
but there are always a little bit below
are the man that's the way it is
do all Nazis agreed each other with a
salute
it depends the the Hitler salute is
forbidden in Germany it's in either way
you do it like Hitler did or with a
resistance w
um or a straight hand out it is all
forbidden you can go to prison for that
or pay like a very big fine like two or
three four thousand pounds
so neo-nazis do it just in countries
where it's allowed
um but it is there are some greetings
like with our comrade group we we
greeted ourselves like this this is like
touching the bloodline yeah and uh there
are some salutes but most of them just
giving a hand like everybody else but
they often say something like like a
hail to you comrade or something yeah do
you have to have a swastika tattoo as a
new Nazi no
today the the people rather say
neo-nazis have to stay away from the
swastika yeah I think there's no other
symbol in the war in the world that you
can shock the people more than with the
swastika and neo-nazis are trying to to
um to pull in people from the middle of
society to their politics and you can't
do that with a swastika so new neo-nazis
try when they get a tattoo not to use
the swastikas anymore for me as a kid
from the 90s it was normal for me
um and for my other comrades to tattoo a
swastika I used to have a swastik area
in the middle
um of my chest I had things like the
roughness s runes and everything on my
body but neo-nazis to today try not to
do to use these things what is the
difference between neo-nazis and the KKK
um the KKK as a cuckoo's Clan from the
US is uh is a very
um it's a white power thing it's a it's
a Southern state thing
um very Christian yeah like some of KKK
say Jesus even was born in the USA we as
neo-nazis from Germany or we looked at
the people from the KKK we looked down
on them
um just like being like sort of rednecks
from the USA not uh deep into politics
um into the National Socialist thing
they're just we just seen them as
racists neo-nazis it's more about
politics and changing the whole system
and the KKK is just a race a racist
Christian thing have you read Mein Kampf
uh yes of course I've read my uh Mein
Kampf it's a book from Adolf Hitler he
wrote when he was imprisoned uh 1923
till 1925. for every National Socialist
in the German movement it is uh it is uh
like a thing you have to do to read mind
Camp it is a very strange book I've read
it two times after my de-radicalization
I thought well what what silly things
and and and and awful things are in this
book when the German people would have
read this book before they would have
known where it would end in the
Holocaust and in a great War
um in Germany you say Mein Kampf is the
most most sword and unread book in
history why do neo-nazis have shaved
heads when Nazis in the 1930s 40s didn't
this came over and was adapted from the
from the right wing movement because it
is like a scary look and when you go
like with 30 40 skinheads down the
street and you're you shout out and
you're like with the tattoos shaved
heads and the boots you just you just
look very scary I think you have to lose
the thought that the skinheads are the
far right now I think this has gone away
this was in the 90s very big in Germany
um it is now that you have like uh like
a shaved head just like I look now today
you have your hair to the side do you
think anyone has the potential to become
a Neo-Nazi we all
um
are proven in our life with sadness and
things happen in our life which makes
times difficult and I think
um in every one of us is a murder yeah
just the right buttons have to be
pressed and the the bad things may
happen or we defend our family and
everything I think you can radicalize
everybody I think that is especially
when when people are young and they are
not not informed about
about life and have problems so I think
yeah everybody can become a new Nazi
would you tell your children about your
past
yeah I have a stepson and he's 13 years
old he's here today with me I think it's
important not to do a secret out of my
life he doesn't know everything I did
but
um I try
um to give him things that I was missing
as a child and to talk about the fears
he maybe has or the fear I had as a
child to
um to try my best that he doesn't go
anywhere on my way anywhere near so yeah
I'm very open to that and I try to talk
to as many children and young people as
I can to warn about this new Nazi
movement and the white power movement
not to go this way not to destroy their
lives or to destroy the life of others
most of the people in the Neo-Nazi scene
are looking for a new fuhrer like like a
strong strong man isn't allowed to be a
woman yeah for a Neo-Nazi so they're
looking for a strong man like German you
say we have to we need a little Hitler
yeah